this method is also cleaned up a bit got
rid of some of the variables that we
don't really need anymore
so the first thing we do is if the user
is null we throw an unauthorized
exception the next thing to do is to get
the main email as the user's email and
get the user id
then we get the display name sent by the
request and the t-shirt size sent by the
request then
this is new
we load the profile might not be there
but we go ahead and load it anyway then
we need to check that it actually
existed so check if it's null then if it
is now that means it didn't already
exist we need to set the display name
either to the value passed in the
profile form
or otherwise if the display name wasn't
passed get the default name and again
similarly with the t-shirt
get the value passed by the form and if
it's now set it to a default which is
not specified in this case not specified
and then
we need to actually create the profile
so this was our call is our call to
create the new profile
however the profile already exists
just call
update method
passing the display name and the t-shirt
size which remember one or either of
these could in fact be null
and then we save it in the data store as
we did before here the code has been
made more concise
and we return the profile now let's take
a look at profile.java to look at the
update method which is pretty simple
takes the display name
and the t-shirt size
checks each one if they're null
if they are null doesn't do anything
with that property if they're not null
that means the user updated that value
so
update the appropriate property that's
all it does
this doesn't do the saving because
remember we do the saving
back here
in save profile
all right let's see if it actually works
so i deployed to localhost
and uh came over to the our old friend
apis explorer we have some profiles so
let's see what they are so get the
existing profile and you see that the
name is apple turnover and the t-shirt
size is xs
so remember that apple turnover xs
now let's save the profile
and we're just going to update one of
the properties let's change the display
name
to
ice cream cake
so we'll save that and the exist
remember that the existing t-shirt size
is excess so let's see what happens
okay good so the display name was set to
ice cream name but the t-shirt size was
size was left as xs so now we know that
we didn't get a new profile we just
updated the existing profile